now if you have a teenager at home i'm
sure you know all about tick-tock but
stars are obsessed with it too but now
the big question is
are its days numbered
[Music]
a lot of people have hopped on tick tock
since quarantine usage has been
skyrocketing
board in the house yeah i'm in the house
board more than 100 million people in
the u.s used the video app but now the
president is threatening to shut it down
over security concerns
the issue is that it's owned by chinese
tech conglomerate fight dance
they're concerned that tiktok could be
leaking data directly to the chinese
government
we're looking at tick tock we may be
banning tick tock
tick tock creators are distraught and
angry we saw some of them
crying telling users to follow them on
instagram and youtube
i've built this huge platform and i
don't really want it to just disappear
a lot of these tick tock users are also
relying on the app for their livelihood
some tick tock creators are making
potentially tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars per
post
charlie dimiglio is the most followed
person on the app she has 75 million
followers on tick tock alone
carol baskin kilder husband
whacked him so could this really be the
end of tick tock
[Music]
that would mean no more wine drinking
from cameron diaz or songs from the rock
well the ban already happened in india
and hong kong users were met with
screens that said
you know this app is no longer available
in this location
the app suddenly wouldn't work on your
phone but tick tock gm says
not so fast we're not planning on going
anywhere
and when it comes to safety and security
we're building the safest app because we
know it's the right thing to do
the president's given a deadline of 45
days and is hoping microsoft purchases
tick-tock to ensure
user data remains in the u.s are the
concerns about security
legitimate maybe sure i mean i think a
lot of them
are it's very important to be skeptical
of any company that's
you know run by china operating in the
us but tick tock is not the only chinese
app that we use
you